as kobit 19 cases remain high flu
activity is
unusually low this year in southern
nevada 8 news now reporter kristen
drummond shows us the latest numbers
from the health district
and the likely reasons for the decrease
a dramatically different flu season
we are seeing less influenza activity
the latest report by the southern nevada
health district shows
zero deaths and only five flu cases as
well as hospitalization
so far substantially lower when compared
to a year ago
data during the same week reveals more
than 460 cases
and hospitalizations as well as 10
deaths
it could be the fact that the flu virus
may not be as severe
as in previous years dr court loaf with
the health
district also credits more people
washing their hands social distancing
and wearing masks
the same safety precautions to try and
fight covid19
influenza is much less transmissible
than
than the covid virus so um
that that could explain the reasoning
why we're seeing less influenza than
than um than cobit we do see a lot of um
patients coming in earlier with any type
of flu-like symptoms because
you know they're concerned they're
worried dr ravi ramanathan practices
family medicine
he also credits the flu vaccine making a
difference
roughly 180 million doses were
distributed
this season increased vaccinations that
have been occurring
this year the medical director of
infectious disease at umc tells me
viral interference is likely happening
as well so something of a competition
between flu
and covariate is leading to much less
glue this year
doctors say the flu is circulating in
the community and the best way to fight
the virus
is by getting a vaccine in the newsroom
kristen drummond 8 news now
and the cdc reports low to minimal flu
activity around most of the country this
year